il y avait dans le nord du québec et du
labrador une population de caribous
migrateurs qui compte parmi les plus
importantes au monde
cette population-là enregistré un déclin
alarmant mais les dernières nouvelles
sont encourageantes
c'est caribou viennent de terminer une
migration longue de 2000 km
[Musique]
le caribou migrateurs de la rivière
george au nunavik était il n'y a pas si
longtemps le plus important troupeau de
calibre en amérique du nord
ce troupeau comptait plus de 800 mille
têtes en 1990 mais ça c'était avant
qu'il n'amorce un spectaculaire déclin
en moins de trente ans il est passé de 8
123 mille à cinq mille cinq cents têtes
une chute de 99 %
pourtant malgré ce déclin inquiétant
le pire est peut-être passé pour cette
population de caribous
[Musique]
coup de théâtre cet été dans le nord
québécois pour la première fois en 27
ans les biologistes ont enregistré une
hausse de la taille du troupeau de la
rivière george cette population est
passée de 5500 à plus de huit mille
bêtes en deux ans une augmentation de
47%
mais comment expliquer ce rebond
il faut d'abord se tourner vers la
qualité du garde manger un meilleur
habitat fournit désormais à ce cervidé
une nourriture beaucoup plus abondante
qu'autrefois
alors à projets en 1990 huit cent mille
caribou broute est chaque jour des
tonnes de graminées et de lichens
ce broutage intensif par complètement
dégradés l'habitat du cervidé et
précipité son déclin al'inverse la
diminution du cheptel va permettre à
l'habitat de se régénérer
[Musique]
résultat les bêtes sont aujourd'hui en
meilleure santé et survivent beaucoup
mieux que par le passé
mais il y a une autre explication et la
voici
le loup principal prédateur du caribou
des scientifiques affirment que la
rareté du loup est un des facteurs qui
expliquent maintenant le rebond du
caribou c'est que les populations de
loups ont elles aussi chuté
dramatiquement en raison du déclin du
caribou c'est donc la faible abondance
de ce grand prédateur qui favorisent
aujourd'hui la survie des jeunes caribou
enfin il ne faudrait pas oublier dans
l'équation
l'arrêt de la chasse une chasse
excessive a précipité la chute du
caribou comme jamais auparavant
cette chasse est interdite depuis 2012
ce qui a aussi contribué au rebond de ce
troupeau
[Musique]
le caribous de la rivière george est il
désormais hors de danger
les biologistes refuse pour l'instant de
parler d'un rétablissement
la population n'est toujours qu'à 1% des
effectifs d'autrefois et québec étudie
toujours la possibilité d'inscrire cette
population sur sa liste des espèces
menacées ou vulnérables
[Musique]
toutefois plus que jamais
les chercheurs sont optimistes la
plupart des facteurs qui ont causé la
chute du caribou sont aujourd'hui
favorables à sa survie mais il faudra
attendre les recensements des prochaines
années pour enfin confirmé le retour du
grand migrateur du nord
[Musique]